There I was and I met a beautiful woman,
the mother of Nigeria to come.
I lived left for 15 years and we are to
have children.
Their eyes there.
Those windows to the soul actually was a
lie.
He was so alive and so sensitive.
She became touched by,
I don't know,
I want to stress because depression came
in.
She became psychotic,
different personalities,
such a beautiful woman.
So the mother of my kids,
my love.
Fifteen years,
she jumped from my eighth story.
I didn't see it coming,
but I saw the declining line of life
getting out of her control that a lot
alone with four kids.
This is life beyond this.
I was hoping and couldn't do anything,
but I always had this deep,
strange feeling.
Something more and I don't know what it
is and it's not in words.
It's a feeling.
It's a grieving from the inside,
from the soul,
from survival,
but it got into me like a flash and I
had to go on the spot to show the world
that we don't need to be powerless in
the face of death,
in the face of darkness,
depression,
trauma,
Ptsd.
Bipolar,
schizophrenia,
it wasn't that I was looking for it,
I just wanted to answers of life like it
is a birthright to know why you're here,
why you're here as a father of two to
bring purpose sense.
That is the simple and it is being
torpedoed that bill bought by all kinds
of things and confusing sets in.
No,
this was too much.
This was the emotional tone in my heart
to be healed.
Not only to become aware of how to do
that and to take away the documents for
those to come.
That was my journey,
so how to begin.
The only thing I had was my instinct,
my intuition.
It's the way it's taught it.
What do you do?
You do 26 rackets in ice.
Cold water is the most dangerous.
You'll go climb mount everest in his
shorts.
That would kill most people.
Use Swim under the ice.
I lose the way and you don't know where
you are and and it's frozen and you
don't know or you go,
you survive.
I was able to stay for five to seven
minutes every time onto the ice and the
only thing I ever ate away at the
bedside,
which we have lost silence is powerful
silence.
It's dense.
It's what I find.
I just wanted to feel good.
I just wanted to feel connected.
I showed him,
but still the cynicism and the market,
not only with the scientists know world,
this mockery,
if it happens 30 years,
35 years,
like decades.
That really gets into you,
but I just feel good so I just follow my
feeling.
Twenty six world records later,
hey,
would I can do anybody can do.
It's not about becoming superman or
superwoman or like these archetypes.
It's becoming you yourself and superior
to what we have learned.
They did an experiment on me with the
Vegas nerve and to see if I was able to
compare to all those who weren't and
yes,
I showed complete control over the vegas
nerve which is dealing with all the
organs.
I don't want to make you nervous system
and it was,
and that means you have influenced their
right.
You have influence on inflammation.
Inflammation is the cause of any
disease,
but he's the iceman we can do with it.
Yeah.
He is an exception that confirms the
rule and I said,
no,
no.
What I can do you can do to that a.
finally they said,
okay,
let's do a comparative study.
How much time do we need to teach people
to get a little bit to the results you
have produced in a laboratory setting?
It took me four days to bring people
both in freezing temperatures without
form experience on wantons cope town.
Four days later,
we had endotoxemia,
everybody doing it and 100 percent score
within a quarter of an hour.
They could suppress it and compare to
16,000
others.
They had to compete to prove outcomes.
That changed the medical books that
year.
Tournament's nervous system.
The innate immune system into Korean
system can be deeply influenced at will.
We have shown that because it was my
wife and I was hopeless then I couldn't
deal with psychosis and depression or
no.
Now I am so far that nature has provided
me with all the insights and Ansys and I
brought it to brain scans,
how to tackle bipolar depression,
how to take over the power of the brain
inside the brain to deal with that what
causes bipolar,
depression,
inflammation in the in the brain because
nature has the answers and what they
think.
Cancer and depression and all those
things only with pills and chemos,
man,
cancer patients,
a million a year.
You don't want to lose those clients
seek well,
we live off people being sick.
That makes a healthy economy.
We are able to change this second world
ruled by people who think they can make
money out of pills and medicines and
think that is the condition of the human
race and we have no other way.
The real terrorists is making us believe
that we are not able to control our
inner physiology.
You know the pharmaceuticals in any
other industry,
how much they use in,
in money for advertising,
for brainwashing.
Our minds making us believe that
dependency in doctors,
healthcare pills and medicines and
therapies,
that is the way to go with hell and not
look within ourselves.
The are the industries will rule over
our moorings and show by data what it is
to go in to the deepest of our
physiology,
at-will that makes us able to get rid of
medicines and pills and changed our
capacity of what we think is possible in
healthcare,
both mentally and physical.
We take out the villain.
We take out a real terrorist which is
killing right now,
millions of people every year and that
war we make visible and that adding,
we are going to take data and bringing
back the belief that we are the masters
of our own mind.